[Musique]
nous sommes le 31 janvier bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 et les invités émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département voici le sommaire
troisième année consécutive à de la
hausse de la mortalité routière en
france l'association prévention routière
invite à repenser l analyse de
l'accidentologie
nous en parlerons avec le responsable
départemental jean yves petit et puis
elle les cérémonies de voeux se termine
pour les élus vendredi dernier c'était
au tour du maire d'elancourt nous
verrons est les priorités de jean michel
fourgous pour sa commune en 2017
nous allons donc commencer par évoquer
la situation sur les routes bonsoir jean
yves petit le directeur dépenses
départementales pardon de la prévention
routière pour les yvelines c'est la
troisième année consécutive et de la
hausse de la mortalité routière en
france et votre association invite à
repenser l analyse de l'accidentologie
c'est à dire on prend le problème par le
mauvais bout de la lorgnette
non c'est pas ça mais il est vrai que
c'était pas arrivé depuis 1972 cette
hausse assez dramatique de la mortalité
durant trois ans donc notre association
a pensé qu'il fallait se doter de
nouveaux outils d'analysé de
l'accidentalité de façon à mieux cerner
les causes des accidents de façon
évidemment à adapter et à mieux cibler
les mesures de prévention alors ça passe
par une
redéfinition ou plutôt une une meilleure
collecte des informations disponibles
un croisement différent et nouveau des
informations disponibles à partir des
open data des big data croiser les
analyses des enfin les statistiques des
hôpitaux des assurances de façon faire
ça différemment de ce que c'est fait
aujourd'hui à l'aide de nouveaux
algorithmes dont je ne suis pas du tout
spécialiste vous avez certainement des
choses un peu compliquées mais dont nous
espérons mieux cerner les causes des
accidents pour mieux trouver des règles
de prévention
lorsque le ministre de l'intérieur bruno
le roux a annoncé une augmentation de
0,2 pour cent de la mortalité routière
pour l'année 2016 ça représente 3469
personnes tuées lorsqu il fait cette
annonce vous vous dites que l'action qui
a été menée jusqu'à présent n'était pas
la bonne
non c'est pas ça non non non
heureusement parce que depuis 1972 quand
même heureusement ça a largement baissé
mais se dire qu'il faut pas baisser les
bras et qu'il faut aller au delà il faut
effectivement se demander pourquoi la
les accidents remonte depuis trois ans
et donc creuser un peu plus via un
relâchement global des automobilistes
des piétons aussi à l'orgue liste les
vrais juillet oui vous avez raison dans
les
la surmortalité par rapport aux années
précédentes
on constate qu il y a beaucoup de
piétons et de cyclistes donc des usagers
vulnérables qui sont parfois d'ailleurs
enfin même assez souvent fautif eux même
s'ils sont victimes d'accidents c'est
parce qu'ils ont commis des imprudences
voire des fautes traversée lorsque c'est
rouge par exemple ça peut paraître un
exposé forcément absolue c'est un risque
d'accident absolument donc et parmi les
piétons
victime il ya eu en particulier dans
notre département beaucoup d'adolescents
beaucoup de personnes âgées ce qu'on
n'avait pas vu surtout pour les
adolescents depuis de nombreuses années
donc c'est un peu inquiétant et il faut
pas baisser les bras et continuer à
faire nos actions de prévention alors
justement vous parlez de ces adolescents
de ces jeunes est ce qu'aujourd'hui la
prévention routière intervient
régulièrement dans les établissements
scolaires par exemple parce que les
actions déjà menées de quel type
eh bien nous allons toute la semaine
nous sommes dans des collèges là deux
collèges du département à carrière
carrière sur scène et puis à chatou où
nous intervenons auprès des élèves de
essentiellement 3e et 5e et nous leur
parlons des règles du piéton du cycliste
et du cyclomoteur les modes de
déplacement qui le pratiquent à leur âge
et ça on en fait l'année dernière en
2007 nous avons fait j'ai pu le chiffre
exact en tête mais dans les trois mille
collégiens à peu près on peut pas être
partout on peut pas tout faire mais nous
sommes là à parler du bilan national est
ce que dans les yvelines la situation
est la même
alors progression de la mortalité dans
les yvelines pendant des années nous
avons eu au nombre près 47 tués c'est un
peu un hasard mais c'était 47 tués
l'année dernière dont enfin pendant en
2015 il y a eu quarante deux tu es
seulement ce qui était un plus bas
historique et 2016 nous sommes
malheureusement remonté à 47 tués
pourquoi 47 j'en sais rien mais c'est le
nombre que nous atteignons chaque année
qui est il faut le dire
nous sommes dans meilleure que la
moyenne nationale nous sommes parmi les
départements vertueux 2010cette année
électorale
on s'en doute on commence à le savoir
vous à les interpeller
j'imagine les candidats sur leurs points
de programme et sur les actions qu'ils
souhaitent mettre en place
oui bien sûr comme nous l'avions fait en
2012 vous avez remarqué alors la
campagne n'a pas réellement débuté
encore mais au moins il ya eu des
élections primaires dans tout le monde a
parlé les la sécurité routière n'a pas
du tout été évoquée dans cette danse est
pré pré pré campagne et élections
élections primaires
donc nous allons effectivement
interpellé les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle quand ils ont été
officiellement déclaré pour leur
demander quelles sont leurs intentions
pour essayer de rallier les directives
européennes en matière d'accidentalité
qui sont vous le savez peut-être ça a
été fixé en 2010 par l'union européenne
diviser par deux le nombre de tués d'ici
2020 ce qui pour la france représente
2000 tuer on en est malheureusement loin
néanmoins les propositions qui ont été
faites parmi ses différents candidats il
ya une proposition notamment qui est la
légalisation par exemple du cannabis on
parle d aider mais fait aussi du
cannabis sur la conduite par exemple
oui ça c'est une mesure qui peut vous
inquiéter certainement oui certainement
certainement le cannabis est tout aussi
dangereux que l'alcool au volant
donc on va pas interdire l'alcool en
était que voilà mais de la légaliser le
cannabis
oui ça serait vraiment un mauvais signal
pour nous
et nouveau enfin nous nous sommes nous
sommes tout à fait opposés à cette
légalisation du cannabis au moins ça
restons dans notre domaine pour ce qui
concerne les conséquences que cela peut
avoir ma question de porter ces
considérations la circulation bien
évidemment sur bien sûr des actions
prévues dans les prochains jours
prochaines semaines pour terminer à bas
sensibilisation du grand public
peut-être oui alors je dois dire un mot
sur les actions nationales
l'année dernière nous avions un grand
fils rouges qui étaient vous sans vous
vous en souvenez peut-être parce que
j'en ai parlé à sur votre antenne 0
enfants tués sur la route c'était notre
combat national
qui s est conclue par un livre blanc qui
a été envoyé au mois de décembre aux
instances européennes et à aux instances
nationales il ya déjà des retours de
parlementaires pour 2017 ça sera sur le
smartphone et le téléphone je connais
pas encore les détails de l'opération
mais ça sera ça le fil rouge pour ce qui
concerne les yvelines à écouter cette
semaine comme je le dis nous sommes en
plein dans l'est dans les collèges ça va
être toute la semaine après les vacances
scolaires va de nouveau y avoir des
collèges et des lycées beaucoup enfin
beaucoup nous allons être bien occupé
puis les entreprises reviendront plus
tôt avec les beaux jours
mais là en ce moment le gros du travail
se fait auprès des collèges et lycées il
vous reviendra plateau nous parler de
ses actions de lutte contre
l'utilisation du smartphone au volant
merci d'être passé sur ce plateau jean
yves petit nous poursuivons donc cette
édition du 7 8 les invités avec la fin
du mois de janvier se termine les
cérémonies et des voeux pour les élus le
maire d'elancourt s'est adressé à son
tour à ses administrés en fin de semaine
dernière à ses homologues aussi des
autres communes le maire d'elancourt qui
est également candidat aux législatives
dans la 11e circonscription cette année
il y avait de nombreuses personnalités
politiques qui étaient présentes gérard
larcher ou encore valérie pécresse
nous avons rencontré le maire
d'elancourt les images sont signées
nicolas landry avec le maire d'elancourt
donc qui vient d'adresser ses voeux pour
2010 est assez différent administré aux
représentants également politiques les
élus les représentants des cultes les
associatifs qui étaient présents bonsoir
jean michel fourgous
bonsoir ce qu'on retient un petit peu du
discours d'aujourd'hui c'est vous êtes
finalement aussi en campagne vous avez
reçu aujourd'hui la visite de nombreux
ténors politiques c'est aussi pour
marquer cette campagne des législatives
on a surtout on reçoit nos partenaires
vous savez aujourd'hui quand vous avez
une baisse de 20% il faut aller chercher
les moyens et des nouveaux partenaires
alors bien sûr on se déplace beaucoup
plus on va chercher les subventions
partout alors c'est vrai que le
président du sénat ça nous aide un
mon madame pécresse c'est pareil sur les
transports on dépend
dell et c'est vrai que cette vague de
modernisation les lignes 18 tout ça
c'est en suisse a avec elle et puis
faire bien des entreprises des talents
des capitaux ici bas bien sûr c'est avec
tous ces réseaux là donc ici vous avez
tous les réseaux qui nous permettent de
réussir tous nos projets sur le fond du
discours on va en parler mais malgré
tout cette présence de ténors j'insiste
un petit peu dessous dessus c'est c'est
important pour vous aujourd'hui
vous savez je vois quoi vous faites
allusion
mais j'ai déjà été parlementaire mons
mais je n'ai pas de déficit je dirais de
je pense de notoriété là-dessus voiliers
mais je suis très sensible par angers
des personnalités de ce niveau là bien
sûr avec moi bien sûr mais c'est moi je
ne sais pas comment enfin si vous faites
allusion à une sélection je sais pas
comment ça se passait alors je sais même
pas quelle est en aide à qui est
candidat vous savez alors bon point ça
on va attendre et on verra à ce
moment-là il a je vous répondrai plus
clairement sur ce sur ce problème
c'est l axe principal de votre discours
du début de disco en tout cas l'économie
les entreprises
vous avez cité ces entreprises qui sont
classés aussi récemment qui on est et
qui figure parmi les les trois plus
innovantes en france qui sont dans le
top 100 mondial au niveau de
l'innovation y en a 3 50 ans il y en a
une à elancourt comment vous pouvez
aussi encourager tout ça au quotidien
elle en cours à saint quentin en
yvelines comment vous devrez pour ça m'a
safran donc valeo et surtout de thales
qui est sur le territoire donc
d'elancourt enfin que c'est le groupe
dassault qui aujourd'hui gère thales bon
bien sûr on est très fiers d'avoir su
les bras devant toulouse comme ça sur le
territoire et on est là encore pour les
aider pour leur simplifier la vie
donc c'est ce que j'ai dit il ya tête 2
3 points de croissance à attendre de sa
vous imaginez si vous trouvez de 3
points de base mais l'amour et vous là
vous pouvez résoudre un problème mais
c'est la priorité ya que ça qui peut
nous sauver
si l'on est en danger alors concernant
la ville d'elancourt quelles sont les
priorités pour 2010 est vous avez évoqué
la sécurité notamment il ya eu le
déplacement de gérard larcher aussi en
début de semaine autour de ce
commissariat qui a fortement besoin
d'être rénové c'est mon qu'on puisse
dire quelles sont vos priorités pour
2010 m sur 7
la sécurité vous l'avez compris donc le
ministre l'intérieur d'ailleurs
paradoxalement à donner le statut
deux commissaires d'agglomération en
cours on est très contents donc ça doit
nous permettent de d'activer le
commissariat avec les pique-niques
notamment numériques
aujourd'hui bien sûr la sécurité ça
s'est transformé et en plus on a lié des
très belles entreprises comme airbus
sécurité défense thales qui sont l'élite
de la sécurité donc qu'il vous dire
qu'avec tous ces savoirs faire demain on
peut vous sortir effectivement ce qui
est de mieux en matière de deux
commissariats du futur oui la sécurité
priorité pour la commune priorité bien
sûr l'emploi
on a un peu moins de 8% de chômage mais
il faut encore améliorer ce n est pas
normal on court on doit faire beaucoup
mieux que ça donc faut intensifier les
forums sur l'emploi intensifier les les
incubateurs que vous avez vu les aides
pour nos entrepreneurs pour ceux qui
créent la richesse l'emploi qui font
rentrer des nouvelles recettes fiscales
et sociales dans les caisses qui va nous
permettre de payer nos retraites 300
milliards m
bien sûr les factures de l'hôpital
bien sûr tout tout tout cela il faut
bien assurer avant tout la durabilité du
financement non nous y sommes des gens
sérieux
on est des gens de droite on est des
gens de l'entreprise on rigole pas avec
la stabilité des financements alors que
on entend plein de choses dans ce pays
où on vous parle de de quelqu'un qui
vous dit allez administratifs ou des 1
400 milliards
enfin on n'arrive pas à trouver 300
millions pour nos policiers ou pour nos
militaires qui en ayant un besoin urgent
à les voir dans quelles conditions
travaillent nos policiers c'est
insupportable et on vous parle de seuil
et moi je donne 400 milliards par an je
distribue enfin bon c'est dit on peut à
sa bête peut développer le sens de
l'humour donc c'est ce qu'on va faire
mais voilà tout cela il faut il faut
être pédagogique avec les français le
travail la valeur travail c'est
fondamental
entreprendre voilà entreprendre innové
en tout cas c'est notre c'est notre
combat ici qu'on fait avec tous nos
partenaires tous les maires qui sont ici
voyons se rassembler 50 ans aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya une dynamique il ya
une dynamique d'innovation qui est très
fort voilà j'essaye de la porter à mon
modeste niveau
voilà mon grand projet faire bouger les
lignes innover augmenter la richesse
augmenter le niveau d'emploi augmenter
les recettes fiscales et sociales pas
promettre 3,5 milliards aller chercher
les fabriques et moi-même d'accord c'est
un peu différent
en plus moi j'ai déjà fabriqué de la
richesse vous savez bon c'est bien les
gens que j'avais produit un niveau de
richesse qui venaient y aura moi je vais
trouver 300 maires bon je préfère chez
pas un bouygues dassault un gars qui a
quatre produits qu'ils m'expliquent
voilà que lui va apporter bon mais on va
y arriver mais on peut traverse
indiscutablement un moment difficile
en france vous avez vu la dette enfin
2200 milliards de dette
80 milliards défis budgétaires qu'il
faut d'ailleurs nous hissions de 9 mais
c'est faux donc c'est vrai que c'est
inquiétant c'est inquiète c'est encore
des marges de manoeuvre ce sera ma
dernière question vous avez encore des
mines malgré les bruits oui si vous
simplifiez parce que ce que j'ai dit si
vous simplifier la vie des entreprises
elles reprennent confiance elles
remettent du capital elle réalise ici
vous pourrez vous remettez la machine en
marche et ce pays regorge de talents on
l'a dit tout à l'heure si vous laissez
les gens qui savent qu'ils sont
compétents qui ont des valeurs morales
si vous êtes ce que je veux dire 1 dans
le travail dans l'entrejeu des valeurs
morales enfin qu'est ce que c'est que ce
ce ce système donc voici vous laisser
ces gens là travailler mais bien sûr
qu'ils ont tout ce qu'il faut pour faire
re décoller votre pays et que vous
retrouver un équilibre bien sûr
budgétaire et donc une redistribution
sociale pour les plus vulnérables pour
moderniser d'autres écoles nos hôpitaux
nous transporte bien sûr j'ai confiance
dans star merci jean michel france
et vous merci c'est la fin de cette
édition du 7 8 les invités rendez vous
demain aux horaires habituels très belle
soirée sur notre antenne
[Musique]